[Musique]
Mme Wang êtes-vous avec nous
je fais attention
maintenant vous ne voyez peut-être qu'une pile de reçus
mais je vois une histoire
je peux voir où cette histoire va
ça n'a pas l'air bien
ce qui se passe
[Musique]
nous avons besoin de votre aide
[  Musique]
très occupé aujourd'hui à la maison pour vous aider à
travers le multivers
j'ai vu des milliers d'évolutions
vous pouvez accéder à tous les souvenirs leurs
émotions
même les compétences
il y a un grand mal qui répand les nombreux
versets
et vous êtes
peut-être votre seule chance de l'arrêter
ne me force pas à te battre je suis vraiment bon
je ne te crois pas
ah ça a l'air vraiment bien
l'univers il parle de
choses insensées est tellement plus grand
que tu ne le penses
[Musique]
souviens toi de notre mission concernant le destin
de chaque monde de  nos motivations infinies
il n'y a aucun moyen que je sois l'éternité
tu cherches
chaque rejet
chaque déception
t'a conduit ici
à ce
moment
ne laisse rien t'en distraire
[Musique]
toi